Hey, it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day
I've been waiting on a sunny day to do this. You remember the last video
I fired a 38 special versus a Prince Rupert's drop, and the Prince Rupert's drop won. Well, we're going to fix that today
We've got the high speed camera back out, and even though it beat
full metal jacket rounds last time you remember I fired the 22 magnum and this particular prince Rupert's drop survived and then I fired the
38 special and it survived. We're to move up here. So now we've got this is my mini 14
It's comparable to an AR-15 except I like Poor Man guns
This is a much different round, a lot higher velocity. It's pointy, I know that sounds silly
But I think it matters
I think a pointy bullet is going to create more of a localized stress on the Prince Rupert's drop
I think it's going to beat it
We've got the AK-47 if the Mini-14 doesn't work and now the AK-47 round, a lot more mass here.
So if that doesn't work, we'll just put more energy into it. Then, if that doesn't work,
Mosin Nagant. If you don't know anything about Mosin Nagant, this is like, it's a big deal.
You can see there's a lot more energy there. Anyway, let's get to shooting.
There's a lot going on here.
It's gone. I think we beat the Prince Rupert's drop. Yeah surely.
Yes, we totally beat it
And there's light!
There's a light that goes off and it turns it into a fiber-optic.
A lot of light, okay this light thing. I want to talk about it
It's something called triboluminescence, and I had to research that because I didn't know about it
You know the Prince Rupert's drop was first investigated in the 1600s right, well the same thing was true for triboluminescence.
Sir Francis Bacon, the father of the Scientific method says this:
It is well known that all sugar whether candied or plain, if it be hard
will sparkle when broken or scraped in the dark. They knew that in
1620. A lot of people don't know that today if you have hard candy thats sugar, and you put it down there.
And you have well-adjusted eyes and you smash it,
you can see sparks.
I think it's amazing that 400 years after triboluminescence was first documented, the scientific community still does not completely
understand what's happening. That's amazing.
That's cool. I want to do it again.
We've got to do the AK just because we can.
That's how that works.
All right, here we go. It's a very expensive camera-mount by the way
No, no
No
We saw the - we saw the light again
There was a localized light this time
It's just a glancing blow, but it was enough to destroy the bullet that's an AK round! Look at that!
Come back. I'm not really aiming. I'm just kind of looking... Oh man, we cut
Okay, weapon's clear. I didn't see any powder. I have no idea what just happened
That thing didn't even try to stand a chance to that
Man
Beautiful. I think we have our answer
once you get
faster bullets that are that pointy
They can easily beat the Prince Rupert's drop. Now we know
Okay, one more thing that falls into the "just because I can" category.
This is the biggest Prince Rupert's drop I've ever seen. It's got like multiple shapes and stuff
It's really scary
I'm going to try to
Set it in tannerite and see what happens when we shoot the tannerite see what a shockwave externally does I don't think it'll break.
I just want to see what will happen
Mom, there's about to be a big boom! Okay, before we go blow stuff up. I've got to share this letter with you
I'm a dad right, so when you get a letter from a little girl named Paisley in California you pay attention. Check this out
Dear Destin. My name is Paisley. I am in second grade. I am seven years old.
I love your videos. My favorite is the tempered glass one because I like to smash things.
But my mom won't let me. Darn it. My mom says I'm crazy because I am. I'm homeschooled
I'm good at art. My dog had puppies. I love science and math I am left-handed. Love
Paisley. Paisley,
This is an adorable letter,
And I thank you very much for it. The really cool thing about this to me though is your name
Paisley that reminds me of the fabric Pattern
Paisley which looks to me like Prince Rupert's drops.
This is really really cool because it made me think about why we don't have a shirt at the smartereveryday
website that has prince rupert drops on it. So you just inspired me to do that. So
Paisley, I'm going to send you a shirt for anybody else. You can go check the shirt out.
But it's for Paisley. One more thing Paisley, your mom who won't let you smash things,
if you tell her you're going to be doing science, she'll probably let you smash things.
Okay, if you want to take the bait go check out the shirts, and you should totally take the bait.
I'll leave a link down in the video description.
You can go to the website while you're there, as you know audible has supported smarter every day for quite a while.
But I've made a website that details every book I've ever listened to on audible and what I thought about it.
It's really kind of fun. Anyway, one in particular
I want you to check out is Ready Player One. On the next episode of no dumb questions,
which is a podcast I do with Matt Whitman. We're going to talk about Ready Player One because it's a discussion we've been wanting to
Have for a really long time.
It's a good book. Probably not for the kids, but it's really deep. If you want to do this with us go to audible.com/smarter
and download Ready Player One or just smash the big red button that I got on the website there. Again
That's audible.com/smarter get a copy Ready Player One and right now.,It's time to go blow stuff up.
Mom, there's about to be a big boom.
Complete professional.
Wow, holy cow it's raining Prince Rupert's drop. That's amazing.
Okie-doke that was fun. Things happened here. Wow
What do you think chicken?